that's test tests one two one two my
check mic check you man a good user
other one today we're live and vibing oh
yeah
that's funny that's funny yeah ma'am
you know what day knock know Jim was
good though mmm so for the people people
mmm
when out last night mmm-hmm kind of vibe
upon vibes from great night yesterday
mmm you were in your element you look
you lookin sexy guides a guy big man
guys to go you lookin eating groovy bro
you pulled it off that red jacket was
fire fire and all black you got move to
sauna hey man
you I didn't I didn't get moved to I
moved to people you won't move to oh yes
well I'm sure you did I don't know I
don't know why as I did but um it was
fine
[ __ ] tired this is the first podcast
I've done where I'm knackered so I'm
intrigued to see I like it I like a more
mellow vibe sometimes so the thing I
wanted to ask you hmm yeah the film want
to ask you is it's like a very kind of
generic question but I've been intrigued
by it for up forever from the stories
that you've told me I've been tricked by
it literally since the dami what's that
I've been African firm in what context
like just like okay what's it like
growing up in an African household it's
very I figured I think
it's a lot it's more time what you think
it is in terms of strict's blah blah
blah all that [ __ ] like especially when
especially growing up like a teenager
and whatnot because I was very
rebellious when I was a kid like how
like why I tried to be anyway always
trying to go out I've never had I never
had a sleepover when I was kid you never
had a summer when I was a kid see what
both sighs you've never been to one
mm-hmm and you've never had one yeah
when I was a kid because my parents
especially my mom she was like what's
wrong with our house why did I come to
my house instead
obviously I've had like we're like
cousins and stuff but like breads from
school I mean never had a sleepover
Jesus Christ
my mom's bro bottle was always that why
didn't it come to mine or like what's
wrong if you stay at home who dem tings
there's like mom that's not the point
I'm gonna try to have a good time my boy
like it's not the [ __ ] point but it's
like she took it to heart they take it
personally I don't know I know it's just
that Africa mentality but later stage
like but when I was in uni and stuff
because we the thing with me and
thinking my sister as well we've both
been away from home mmm throughout the
majority of adult life
like even even in school from um
boarding school went to boarding schools
I went to uni in Coventry and obviously
I moved to Manchester no me being away
from that from like the normal growing
up householders isn't new to me but they
were very very strict on us very very
strict I used to get beat for joke
I've still got a scar my stomach I've
got a police car my stomach from what
fam so check this oh yeah check this so
back I was I was a little teeth back
then yeah teeth Isis still money just to
buy sweets for no reason this was back
in primaries yeah everyone did though
the funny thing was that fun from this
experience with their scar I've got my
stomach I took money from my my aunt who
was staying with us at the time Wow but
coincidentally money was missing from a
mum because back then ourselves and
likkle teef so my mom used to count her
cash all the time all the time so she
wouldn't know where Sian's gone missing
she would [ __ ] know
so I obviously they suspected me I was
getting the wickedest licks from head to
toe the wickedest I'm Arnie was I was
staying with us at a time because my dad
that was beating me my I was begging and
pleading like stop stop stop stop stop
if it wasn't hit because obviously I was
saying it wasn't me it wasn't me save
you saying it so she said to my dad or
if he's saying it's not him it's not him
bla bla and these times I stole from her
so I couldn't even be like do you know
what [ __ ] it
oh I couldn't even like I had to firm
the light a deferment
so yeah but getting beat was standard
for me so obviously I don't get beats
now like nowhere near I think the last
time I got beat was [ __ ] you know yeah
you're 11 maybe mm I don't know it must
have been silent I honestly can remember
and I'm 28 now so I was like a decade
ago whatever yes or even more than more
yeah [ __ ] no yeah a lot more than
that no like growing up in Africa house
like it's very very different other
cultures in the sense that they're very
Africans are proud mmm they're proud
people so whatever happens in house
whether it's good or bad it stays in
house kind of thing and they don't want
people to know they don't want other
people to know our business and stuff
which is I feel like that's the generic
in Africa of like just my family or
Nigerians I think that's as generic in
an African household kind of thing
they're very very like expect that and
they're very religious as well like my
MA I've seen my family's Muslim which we
obviously know and I've always wanted me
to always wanted me to try and adopt the
faith and obviously as a kid I used to a
lot like a lot a lot because it was
that's what I was taught that's why I
used to go to mosque bla bla bla but I
just fell out of it because I felt like
I just wasn't being me you know she lost
not really force per se but I was just
used to going because that's what I was
told to do kind of thing and then I just
got to a stage where I just didn't want
to go anymore
obviously my parents always told me all
you need to pray you need to believe in
God which I which I'd obviously still
believe in God but I'm not actively
religious but my sister really is yeah
purely because well she was before but
now that she's married she is if she is
even more because her husband she met
her husband at mosque yeah so that then
obviously just solidified her faith even
more which is a great thing for her like
I would never knock her house or
anything like but the thing is me and my
sister are polar opposites mmm
polar opposites she doesn't she rarely
goes out she doesn't drink her husband
has never had a drink in his life or
them like when I say were polar
opposites but we respect each other like
um I'm her brother she's my sister at
least she knows how I am and I know how
she is
mmm we don't talk to each other everyday
but if I need side or vice versa kind of
thing might spoke to her I spoke to her
on the phone sometime last week and I
said obviously now she's got I've got a
little nephew so I'm gonna go down even
more so it's just African households are
mad but I feel like African households
in for our generation like when we will
start having kids are gonna be very
different
yeah we're in Western civilization yeah
Africans coming from Africa to live in
England all yeah and live yeah to bring
your children up so I think this
generation of kids is gonna be
completely different completely
different so what I haven't used to oh I
was used to mmm-hmm kids like when I
nowadays when I go to like other
people's houses and stuff I just know
it's a difference in the way in a way
that day-to-day life is in term I can't
give an example I could just I can just
tell what you know I mean hmm African
house is just completely different
completely different but this is just
what I'm used to in it because every
time I talk to like an African person
it's always far it's always something
it's always something like it's always
no it's always like a story of like how
I got beat for this
oh yeah rags burn you tell me oh never
sleepovers never been toys are
I've never been to ToysRUs and I never
will obviously because they shot what do
you mean never been stories are us bro I
know Toys R Us I know that's just it I
know if I'm never been if you're not a
child if you haven't been Toys R Us you
just go there I remember my mom would
take me there to get something random
yeah like a [ __ ] I don't even know
just like a beyblade or some [ __ ] mhm
and then you'd end up shooting hoops in
the [ __ ] basketball hoop that they
got there you get one of the bikes and
start will just rock around on the bikes
they'll have like a trampoline and you
try get on a trampoline and stuff like
that it's just mad in there probably
it's just sick I miss the [ __ ] out I
know I did
why the [ __ ] didn't they take you to
Toys R Us no bro did they get you toys
for him I think I've just had my
Playstations and stuff I didn't have
like like toys toys I don't balls and
stuff and places buddy my boys like to
run around in the yard if they weren't
about that they ain't got time to mess
that up and the thing is I didn't I
didn't feel a different that didn't have
it you know I mean yeah yeah it's like
since I didn't have any sleepover so
there was no jealousy involved yeah yeah
so yeah were you ever like growing up
like we've when if you have had friends
who like one African were you very
conscious of the fact that if they come
round it's gonna be different to what
they used to yeah always
you knew that always yeah especially
when I was a lot younger yeah like when
I was in secondary school but a lot of
my secondary school friends were either
Nigerian or African mm-hmm so obviously
that's just a crowd well that's that was
just the crowd I was with because my
form and all of that [ __ ] that was just
a crowd ohs with but even like even like
cuz my mom came my mom came here
obviously she met Bella
hmm but now it's totally different
because she knows how I am kind of thing
and I had no qualms of her or Bella
meeting them to meet in each other
because I knew was gonna be true that my
mom and my mom loves everyone graduation
graduation yeah yeah yeah but yeah man I
just yeah I just think like all the
stories are here there's always feeling
like [ __ ] you now yeah [ __ ] you now
a different dog different but it builds
character from mmm it just it just
built-in us that's why I say our
generation when we start having all
Africans not having kids now it's gonna
be so different to what us as teenagers
were used to hmm
like dramatically dramatically
especially like people like me at that
obviously I adopt my culture by don't
adopt it on day to day lifestyle not
surrounded by Africans were surrounded
by Nigerians yeah yeah and nine times I
said I'm probably not gonna marry a
Nigerian anyway mm-hmm so because you
know I mean how you gonna probably make
a good [ __ ] man in a dress
oh mama knows that as well
that's calm as long as she knows firm
yeah that's all right I've got nothing
against them obviously like I love them
is what it is right as mad because I
just always find it interesting
obviously my childhood was completely
different from complete your mom was
white
and it's just bless it was just bless
you had a good good we had a good man
obviously but mom was Irish tomorrow
nice to beat the [ __ ] out of us as well
but it was never like I'm never gonna
have a scar like we need to
I was four I got beat in it and then you
didn't get firm I was smacked not good
yeah I didn't get beat I got smacked so
compared to us yeah we go I thought I
broke I thought I got beat until I'd
hear so many stories and then I'm having
belts scars BAM my dad like dazed me one
day days me I remember so black it I
think I've told you this story before
back in the days were secondary this was
primary school was the primary cause
primary school Yale was primary school I
wasn't even in Crystal Palace back then
so I had a had a drawer of clothes that
I knew I shouldn't wear to school
because there were nice clothes like
nice ones that you went up for like food
and stuff yeah so there's I remember
wore polo top a pony a blue polo coming
what making was by new I knew I should
have worn it but awful [ __ ] let me
look good today
he [ __ ] look good today for these
little these little things these little
things in year six yeah I was like let
me look good worst mistake of my life
add art that day I'll never forget
scattered Matty luckily up
brought another did I bring yes of
luckily I brought another tea or did I
I didn't I didn't bring another tea hmm
but so I was on my way home I was
walking I was off prank powering it
everything everything
because I knew for a fact this shirts
day regardless to the fact that I knew
we could have gotten washed or whatever
but I knew I should have worn it so I
got I got home yeah and to get to my
laundry room at 2 past the kitchen here
and my pops was home yeah at the time he
was in the kitchen so I walked in
whatever dinner thing walked straight to
the laundry room took the T off put it
in a basket and it walks back to go
upstairs
my dad clocks he was like where's the
shirt you wore to war to school like why
you topless kind of thing I was like oh
it's an allergy mask it was like why is
it an orgy Oh big man is Barry what do
you he took you out was painting
everywhere everywhere I knew it was a
mistake he knew I [ __ ] up fan this
what he gave me one bang on my chin firm
but you should you mean not miss not
obviously you ordered I'd not fist but a
slap fan I thought I felt like I saw
stars that day he slapped the [ __ ] out
of me Jesus [ __ ] don't forgetting your
shirt day I'm glad you can laugh at this
I'm [ __ ] glad this is years ago years
and years and years ago there was
another time
[Music]
yeah so there's another time I can't
remember
oh this is it so back to me stealing
money like when I was a kid known for to
buy sweets and stuff so I stole money
from my mom to buy sweets when I took it
to school mmm my dad came to school
mid-shift like mid mid school because my
mom my mom clots that she was missing my
car my family could have been to pound
it could be five fun obviously back then
it was a lot more money back though
terms of value was a lot more money okay
he came to go around 1:00 p.m. like mid
lesson and like my teachers lollipops to
sales like the [ __ ] he came in because
there was two entries still that's the
main indoor entrance any outdoor edges
he came from me outdoor edges
who came in lost through my bag and cut
the Swedes say unless he said I'm gonna
pick you up tonight it's like he came
all the way to your school just to
search your bag says yo my guitar man
he's picking me up tonight James my
heart left me left me I was thinking of
all excuses to stay in school all
excuses when a free of crock rolled
around I was petrified petrified
petrified it rode up
it was our way to get his Caesar I was a
boy from the shops that where'd you get
the money from a caramel I said we went
to the shop he took me to the shop
and it was like he asked am i man did
this boy come and buy sweets off you
today as soon as my mind said yes they
eat turn round and dazed me in the shop
in the shop and Gina was obvious funny
nuts I don't give a [ __ ]
oh my Jesus Christ do you know what's
funny if there was a woman there with a
baby girl she held her baby family just
had her grandfather you slapped me down
the aisle and back up the aisle and then
left and the thing that vex me so much
was the my man had no care for his shop
because when he slapped me like a
scattered things you know I mean like
you know when you're disoriented
ya know care and then when we left I
looked at my man he smiled he's smarter
just and just let me walk out if I me
didn't have no care in a ward for sure
Wow camera wow
these boys Wow remember that
specifically that and the the scar one
on my stomach I remember those to you
specifically Jesus Christ bro
what was the scar from well what did he
use ah he used one stick from a tree
firm like a like a bamboo thing that
wouldn't break yes stretchy oh yeah and
I was I remember I was on one side of
the table he was on the other side I say
I was figuring I'm nice
fabbi tor masking off he's still there
to this day
that's called child abuse that's the
definition firm is it what do you mean
easy yes as I showed you it yes African
household famis what we used to this is
why I had to ask what he was like Jesus
Christ that's actually nuts oh no that
is not no [ __ ] I don't know why this is
completely off-topic did you ever have
many fights in school I've never had a
fight in my life anyway you've never had
one fight I never had one fight my boy
of her fights you don't know the fear
then there's no point even talking about
cause and you don't know the fear that's
one time there was one time there was
one time I was in like year 8 or year 9
this is how pay school was there was one
girl that she used to go out of one my
man hoo-hoo it was [ __ ] like he was
nut you know you get this what that one
road man in your school that was quasar
there's a guy called Quincy he was
Albanian his name is quasar he was the
road disk of road men I'd never
approached him from never wore chains he
was oh he was told in year 12 bro yeah
12 year 10 this end was talk I find him
this guy was cool [ __ ] I remember
roar brother his name was Rory that's
what you know your gang 1 mix race you
call Rory brough he loved to fight guys
he didn't give a [ __ ] he loved to fight
guys so he was going out with his girl
he must have got expelled from school
whatever yeah they broke up she started
moving to your boy I'm obviously game
yes oh yeah yeah we start going now yeah
boy a girlfriend
boyfriend-girlfriend thing and in my
mind I was sharing a wall hmm
talking [ __ ] with the boys and were like
yeah yeah yeah and then my mom was to
come to the gate so when the gate was
you could just walk up to the gate
obviously yeah and then he was just like
yo James I'm like awesome man you good
yeah yeah yeah are you going out with
them
what was her name their name was Leon
yeah it's like you go over Lea and I was
like Leon yeah and I was like yeah I
mean I don't know about going out what
kind of I don't know yeah we talked
sometime huh and he's all right cool
yeah and no worries and I'm like all
right place is like cool I'm gonna fight
you after the school fam so nonchalant
he was he didn't give a [ __ ] he can [ __ ]
about me or himself he's all right cool
yeah I'm gonna fight off school and I'm
like why man and he's like ah obvious my
girl
and now sugars I'm gonna fight here I'm
gonna beat the [ __ ] I ever slept and
then like I'd turn around to my boys and
you have to play it calm you have to
play a calm language to this guy man and
then oh boy that's a piece kid my
stomach my stomach plagues my stomach he
was doing back flips I know that a way
to [ __ ] I know that feeling vomit with
your heart I was like I'm gonna get
banged after school thanked and she's
gonna see it everyone's gonna everyone
does it I was so sure like I was
counting down minutes and I remember I
was walking into I was walking into form
after lunch form and she felt it up the
stairs yeah she was like divorce he's
gonna fight yeah and I was like yeah
it's a summer day yeah that's my knife
yeah what yeah yeah yeah we're gonna
fight and then she was like crying
[Music]
he's gonna he's gonna [ __ ] kill me
oh that's so scared I've never been so
scared in my I don't know why kids made
a room you said your dad came in in the
case yeah that's the thing that came to
my head and I was like bro do mama not
go to your school
yeah he got expelled bro oh I was
thinking why yeah bro expelled for
[ __ ] fighting did you fight him on
our now I don't know what happened but I
must have I had I remember had a an
athletics tournament yeah I don't know a
flex tournament after school so I'm just
rolling out and I'm like I'm not looking
for this guy
yeah if he wants to fight me he's gonna
have to approach me yeah I'm not gonna
hunt him down all right just give thanks
yeah walked out he was there and I was
like right I'm shook and then nothing
happened I just walked kind of not
directly past him but like probably that
20 feet away walk to the gym where I was
gonna get ready to go to my tournament
and nothing nothing squared for me but
brav when I say I was scared day in day
out for weeks and weeks and weeks I
wanted to dump the [ __ ] out of this girl
bruv
I want to dump the [ __ ] ever but I
couldn't you couldn't he's all stuck
between a rock and a hard place because
if I dumped her then a like a [ __ ] oh
yeah but if I stay with her I'm gonna
get bang mmm brother skid so somehow it
fizzled out he ended up going to Penn
for stabbing a guy when we were like 14
oh wow bro he yeah yeah yeah he he was a
[ __ ] fighter as Christ but yeah bro
it was I don't know why that puts on my
head but yeah that was that was a time I
calmly you've got way of not having a
single fire in your life to be fair no
you haven't time cuz my temple was
swollen for weeks because he I was
scared to go sleep I thought I wasn't
gonna wake up oh my gosh dramatic bro
anyway oh my god that's funny Randy Andy
you know DejaVu not the movie about like
the experience they javac yeah yeah one
how the [ __ ] does it come about and to
who was the first man that clocked deja
vu and then quayne dit de ja vu do you
know I mean what language is it I think
it's French is actually I think it
sounds French deja vu
it sounds French to me does sound it's
not English obviously yeah yeah how the
[ __ ] do you get deja vu I don't even
know that things
random things are that blow my mind yeah
but I've had times I've had times deja a
few times where like I don't know I'm
like certain that the conversation that
I'm currently having I had a dream yeah
or I've had it before I've had it in a
dream and I feel like I know what
they're going to say next but I've never
I'm never like I'm never confident
enough in where like I can jump the gun
and be like he's gonna say this because
it's obviously not real yeah bro you can
sound like an idiot but like I don't
know de ja he's a weird thing I don't
even know where to get it I'm gonna have
to Google you know what that's actually
fine sign out for once they shall V I'm
sure it's French food origin deja vu
French nice so what is data of you
caused by what already face translates
to already seen one explanation for deja
vu is that there is a split second delay
in transferring information from one
side of the brain to the other one side
of the brain would then get the
information twice once directly and
watch from the incharge side huh so the
person would sense oh okay cool so make
sense I was about attention from family
you here are you here sir are we doing
this or we're not
[ __ ] you meaning you out you how are you
in that's funny
jesus [ __ ] christ yeah basically is
saying when you so if you say something
now
my eye my ears hear my brain processes
it and it needs to travel from one side
of my brain to the other okay but
there's a slight delay
mmm so it doesn't just hit my brain all
at once so I'll hear you say it and then
there's a slight delay and then this
side will process it so it sounds like
I've heard it before
does that make sense yeah that makes so
it's just a memory at that point oh
that's that's what [ __ ] says it says
you know it's also weird when I have
dreams and then like I hear a sound like
a knocking sound like let's say for
example I mean I'm having a dream sleep
and have a dream but someone's knocking
on the door where in my dream someone's
knocking on a door as well at the same
time yes I don't know why it has that
it's weird he's weird
[ __ ] your brain automatic it's like
Inception to remember yeah and it was
like as shit's happening your brain just
compensates and then makes up a smarter
to accommodate what's actually happening
broken nails mad the human mind is a
bonkers thing it's so much it's crazy
how much the brain is mmm it's
ridiculous it's one of my mind makes me
so sad I just wanna [ __ ] know oh my
god Jesus oh my god but now I don't know
I'm tired from [ __ ] tired it's been a
long day mmm you have four [ __ ] hours
I needed it and you did fat it bro I
need it tonight
absolutely shouts it Bravo just want a
cuddle he's mad rather than putting the
feelers out big haha big man I just want
to squeeze a te nice dog nice I love
cuddling I love small spoon
I love being small spoon best feeling
ever
mmm eh oh well
hmm you know editing said anyway let me
see if I had something I wanted to say
to you it's [ __ ] piss go Pisco Pisco
piss off at my firm it just copies now
Oh MIT fam all right
I'll tell you what mmm completely
different topic yeah but this is gonna
go as this one I'm saying you if you
want a piss go now fine because we're
about to get into the NASPA - all right
cool so one topic I was thinking about
the other day just popped in my mind
yeah you know when people check through
their partner's phone yeah
and obviously breached that trust yeah
and [ __ ] do what they shouldn't be
doing yeah why the [ __ ] do they do it
why do they do it the impulse of doing
it yeah well not necessarily the impulse
I can always understand an impulse of
doing something but especially if they
do it multiple times so scenario mmm
which happens to pretty much anyone who
goes through anyone's phone ever
yeah so you with you lady yeah you go
for a piss she goes through your phone
mmm she sees a text she doesn't like or
worse worst case scenario she finds
[ __ ] nudes or saying from some girl
in your phone right yeah she then
confronts you about it you argue you
squash it you move on and you're happy
again you move on from the chick or you
move on from the situation moving on
from the situation
so you kiss basically kiss you kiss and
make up bases yeah yeah
so she checks your phone you argue kiss
and make up
yeah you're all good to go yeah so then
she checks your phone again in a few
months
mmm just like he said impulse shakes her
phone again she finds saying no she
doesn't like mm a text to someone or
maybe a text between you and your boy
talking about some girl something yeah
she confronts you about it you argue
yeah you kiss her makeup yeah you move
on yeah if she's not going to dump you
yeah why the [ __ ] does she want to go
through your phone because she only goes
through your phone because she suspect
she's gonna find something yeah and she
does find something but then that just
upsets her yeah and but she's not gonna
dump you over it mmm
but this she's gonna check your phone
again and upset herself again where is
if she didn't go for your phone she
would just be happy yeah
would just be happy and another thing is
is like no one goes through your phone
I've never heard like no one ever picks
up someone their partners phone go
through their [ __ ] doesn't find anything
and they're like oh that's good like
he's a good man
relieved yeah yeah thank God they feel
disappointed that I've not found some
right there we'll find something we'll
find some they're not gonna stop until
they find something something to bring
up yeah anything will cause them to
switch they're not want to be happy
clearly not people not want to be happy
in a relationship don't wanna sabotage
[ __ ] I hate bro I can't stand it I
physically can't stand it no one does it
to me but I can't stand it's been done
to me oh and I remember one time I was
in a relationship and then it was
happening all the time and the [ __ ] that
we were arguing about was so stupid and
irrelevant so [ __ ] stupid and
irrelevant and we'll go through it and
go through it and I was [ __ ] funny
this is before fingerprint [ __ ] oh you
know when you're young in your
relationship and it's just that whole
like what's your what's your passcode
like you know we need to be knowing my
passcode well if you trust me or if
you've got nothing to hide
then give me your passcode give me a
basket if you've got nothing to hide I'm
sorry Fox they can I used to fall into
that [ __ ] honeypot
every single time and they should go
through my phone would argue about
something stupid and then broke I got so
vexed one time I'm going through her
phone yeah like I'm not going to sit
there and take this up I'm gonna go for
a friend bro I went for a phone and I I
had to I stopped myself Midway because
just like this is the dumbest most
pointless [ __ ] exercise ya ever like
why would I do this yeah and I just
didn't understand why someone would
intentionally tried to make themself
unhappy yeah by going through your phone
and trying to pick up on something to
pick up start an argument no why
mmm girls love to hug you though you
always love to argue to probably
solidify what their relationship is to
see if I feel like they feel like
arguments are healthy to make a
relationship lately I feel like yeah
yeah yeah I've heard people say that
before like I've heard people say that
like oh we've never argued like do you
think that's right like me and my
boyfriend I've never argued if like
that's there's something wrong that we
don't argue that's fine okay Hugh man
that's perfect so you been saying why do
you need to argue Rob asked me how many
times I've known you for like a decade
now we've already argued once or twice I
remember towards every argued in history
in history over a [ __ ] that was funny
over a woman that was funny yeah that
was - oh my god the way you're George I
couldn't cry my wife said to you but
your drill [ __ ] draw I can't remember
what I can't even remember what was said
I told me I remember on that you came
down the stairs
and I was outside you said something at
my jaw hit the floor I couldn't believe
it I couldn't believe it over a woman
you know that was funny
that was funny stupid oh my god but yeah
like we don't argue yeah
but boy I think differently to girls man
all the time boys are wait we can go day
or day in day out be nonchalant and
that's the difference between having a
male best friend and a female having a
female best friend mmm like like you
said we don't argue we got no knees
we've got no reason to argue I can speak
my mind singing and vice versa
yeah whereas I feel like certain not all
females but a lot of females friend or
best friends they pussyfoot around what
they want to say to the girl because
they don't wanna hurt feelings but if
you're a real true girl or true best
friend wherever you and have to feel
that way you can just say what you want
to say - they go hmm and then hopefully
they would be able to take it as like
criticism and not not think like oh I'm
trying to [ __ ] make you feel
miserable and blah blah blah why would
you say this to me and bubble do you
know I mean mm-hmm whereas guys we just
say on a chin and I know I'm not gonna
be a [ __ ] of I it's just facts whatever
you need to say to me I'll take on the
chin and vice versa you know ask me my
truth - yeah yeah but obviously goes are
a lot more sentimental than guys because
we just we just keep it pushin doesn't I
think that's a huge difference
so when you say like girls going through
guys phones and stuff they do it cuz
they're a lot more sentimental and they
they want to find I feel like they want
to not want to find something but if
they do find something to be like [ __ ]
I [ __ ] knew it
dunno I mean yeah a guy I wouldn't ever
be sat with that shake and be like I
want to go for a phone like it would
never come to mind mmm and I wouldn't
really give a [ __ ] laughs I've chilled
roof girls before and their phones are
upside down on it it doesn't bother me
but in the same breath I'm thinking are
you doing that to protect you or are you
doing that because your Heinie's
something but within the same breath
like I don't really I don't care that
much even if your phone does pop up with
messages like I couldn't really care
less because my phone is always like
this my friends up but the difference
with my phone is that or you can't see
any previews on anything doesn't
whatsapp iMessage and it's been like
that for years all the same and it's
name we've what's up I don't kick some
awesome and it's been like that for
years yeah because I'm having anything
but that's just is my phone in it could
be public and anyone could be my message
I'm not about that life you set your
settings to me so if you want to put
your phone upside down maybe it speak up
for the same reasons but I still feel
like girls wanna find stuff as much as
they don't want to find something they
want to find time to prove a point and I
feel like the reason why they do it is
because
of their [ __ ] group chat their group
try is always in their [ __ ] ear
girls girls oh my god oh my god it makes
me sick because I know for a fact that
the reason why girls do certain things
or girls say certain things is because
they're girls taught them to do it or
say it
brav they hunt one hunt they can't think
for themselves of [ __ ] [ __ ] time
oh I've been back and forth of a girl
whatever going through it and then she
was like well I spoke to my friend about
it oh here we [ __ ] go brother your
friend has nothing to lose your friend
was used to be [ __ ] unhappy and
single your friend has nothing to lose
Oh like don't don't take your friend's
[ __ ] advice yeah there not been a
situation like to deal with the
proportions of what she's [ __ ] saying
uh she just wants to and she wants the
drama yeah he wasn't a gossip of what
what do you say what you're going
through
yeah and she wants to be your shoulders
crying it'll be alright you find someone
else nah they're all trash not all these
man a trash
don't talk to my babes no he will you
ladies I don't talk to my babes yeah
talk to my babes but leave her alone
leave her the [ __ ] alone it's such here
don't be in a group chat telling her to
do this and to do that she's an
independent black woman yeah and I do
what she wants prosthetics files funny
and a fingers as much as any girl would
hate hearing what I've just said they
know it's true
and that's the reason why I'm happy I
live with Bella and I know that's the
reason one of the reasons why she's
happy lose me because I I give her the
[ __ ] truth I don't [ __ ] for if she's
if there's a situation where I feel like
she's in the wrong or I feel like she's
being a [ __ ] Allah boy I'll tell her
straight and I feel like girls wouldn't
do that for girls yeah yeah they'll be
like they'll be soft soft around in
[ __ ] like I said [ __ ] for in a round
hole situation it's like that's not what
she needs to hear it sounds like a
[ __ ] waste man you need to [ __ ]
speed facts not be a [ __ ] tuna melt
like it's it's back it's true it's true
man and it just depends on how severe
you get with the obviously Bella's used
to me being up
so I can say who I want and be how I
want with that but other girls I don't
know mum
I don't you look you'll I tell me like
if I'm wrong which I'm not I'm not wrong
but you're like I'm wrong then you know
I mean speak the truth but yeah I need
um yeah
young plug I'll do a quick plug now I
need I need some females to send me some
messages because I've had a couple
already on the Instagram page send me a
message and like if you listen to these
things and you have an opinion on it
send me a message and tell me or tell us
because I want to hear the woman's
perspective of what yeah I'm saying yeah
because I don't [ __ ] know yeah I'm a
neat brother I don't [ __ ] you know I was
only chat talking [ __ ] I don't know
but opinion yeah and I'd like to be
proved wrong but yeah
like it's just the differences between
male and female sometimes it's just
really it's astronomical birthday really
per be in my [ __ ] body
they really do it gets on my [ __ ]
tits
it does mum very very very random you
know you know girls with tattoos why
does why does every girl have that
[ __ ] chandelier tattoo on their chest
you know which one I'm talking about
well if I tell you why every go as the
[ __ ] chandelier tingle her chest the
same reason why every girl has a [ __ ]
fight ie and the same reason what's the
other one
so it's the thigh tattoo this thing
under the tea I was here for one what's
the there's another tattoo Ariel ting
that every girl has to have it drives me
nuts I can't [ __ ] remember but
because they can't think for themselves
you just say they're min ago true so
many girls have that [ __ ] I don't even
know what it's not actually not
chandelier it looks like this thing I
don't know it is you will know I'm
talking about if you're a female you
know and you've probably got yourself
you've got one you you're one of your
girls is going you think why
what is that tattoo and why do so many
girls have it it blows my mind I think I
think Briana's got one and I think she
like quaint it yeah yeah I was like the
thing every chick Under the Sun wanted
to get that tire I was like [ __ ] it I
want to shine the enormous
as well hmm I don't I generally don't
understand that sausage yeah boy it's
just like he's charged before I find a
lot of obviously there's trains to
things yeah yeah I thought [ __ ] talk
I've got a sleeve every guy's about
[ __ ] sleeve but yeah it's just all to
be fair we'll save it for tomorrow bro
I'm literally I have a thought in my
head about the way women think and it's
just it's controversial I'm too tired to
really explain what what I'm trying to
say yeah so it would just come across as
me sound like a [ __ ]
okay first so I'll talk about tomorrow
and I've got more pizzazz but yeah women
have an injured remind me tomorrow when
we do the next one
you remind me tomorrow to just say said
what wanna [ __ ] say so when I want to
[ __ ] say about how these women act
how they [ __ ] think remind me
tomorrow [ __ ] to get off my chest sound
fun that's hilarious
up in her oh my god but yeah I think
there's a sure one but you want to wrap
it it was a good cheeky one